how many women does it take to run a
restaurant badly
three is called Morgans
you better watch out because we're gonna
get him I'm grappling with girl power to
save this restaurant you with us it's
going to be handbags at dawn with mum
don't tell me to shut up
and sibling rivalry is driving me
demented you tell these people do my
roles
that's typical foreign
[Music]
Liverpool a city that's sheddling its
run down reputation with rocketing house
prices and three billion pounds worth of
investment it's rapidly becoming hip and
trending
[Music]
18th century Wilton Village is one of
the city's most affluent and exclusive
suburbs
this is a typical sort of footballers
wise hangout there must be a great
catchment for ladies who lunch
especially all these amazing houses
[Music]
at Walton's heart lies Morgans
three years ago Sandy Morgan was an
antique dealer before she changed her
shop into a restaurant the idea actually
started we're actually having dinner one
night and I just said well she used to
cook for pregnancy now tent into a
restaurant and thought great why not
Sandy runs it with her two daughters
Helen and Laura
we've pulled together Fort together
we've lost together cried together every
emotion you can ever imagine how we're
all still talking to each other I don't
know
with no customers and a hundred thousand
pounds worth of debt the women will lose
everything in six months just doesn't
doubt you're doing it for themselves
maybe that's why we need a bit of a
testosterone from good
thank you thank you
from the outside looks very romantic you
know perfect High Street local eatery
let's get some dinner
my name is Helen Helen how are you Dolly
nice to meet you
and this is I'm Sandy Sandy please what
a beautiful place
I'm fine are this is nice it's beautiful
do you like it and these girls serve
here as well everything all good all
around us I have a single male in
Liverpool
how many books there's a table at two
and a half six it's weird I mean we're
in September it's a sort of Indian
Summer's evening out there and you've
got two booked yeah
a lot of tweaking
the business
three of us three of us taking
responsibility for maybe one job three
managers sounds like too many chiefs to
me I better eat yes
beautiful little smart restaurant very
romantic and everything's slightly uh
weird apricots in a cream mashed potato
with Lincolnshire sausage
vanilla and Whiskey sauce with a fillet
of beef
this isn't the sort of menu that ladies
who lunch want even I don't know what
kind of menu this is
the food is French English a la carte we
sort of bring entire influence you know
um
Spanish it's English a la carte really
on one plate sometimes you can get two
or three different nationalities
Phyllis Morgan's cocky but inexperienced
head chef
gotta be confidence in your own ability
of and you'll otherwise putting this
with being a chef I need one soup one
prawns one sausage one beef pink and one
portion of eggs
thank you lovely pan-fried prawns
it's my paprika
they're absolutely solid I mean really
solid no film orange segments lemon
segments in there and prawns are just
bullets hard disgusting bullets
[Music]
thank you
this dish is big enough for a dinosaur
it's like something out of Jurassic Park
sausage on T-Rex
a cherry tomato with mashed potato laced
with [__] apricots that is pretty
dismal
this huge dish of overpriced starch
should be extinct no wonder the locals
aren't coming here no one's gonna sit
down and even attempt to eat substantial
mountains of food that doesn't make
sense like that nowhere near it
um
Junior sous chef Emma is Phil's
long-suffering sidekick her star turn is
sticky toffee pudding but Phil hates it
babe you know my feelings on this
[__] I know you don't like the book
day one I've always said it should not
be on our menu Neil turned on and go
what is that what is that and it'll be
told it's the Morgan's classes
smell nice
[Music]
it's the first time I've seen it I'm
glad to be here this is nice light
not too sticky the person who made that
dish doesn't put [__] apricot and
mashed potatoes together and vanilla
whiskey
talking up got a kid haven't you what he
thinks
yeah well
thanks a difference
okay anyway it started off good I
arrived and I thought it was actually
quite a stunning intimate little place
then the food arrives
solid rock hard prawns you dig deeper
and you come across the mashed potatoes
got lace with [__] apricots tomatoes
and a red currant juice
what the [__] were you thinking about
putting apricots inside mashed potatoes
do you know what Rose I actually took
the recipe from the good food magazine
the good food magazine that's the
[__] answer what were you thinking
about putting it together well why not
it's different you've got every right to
be slightly [__] off about it
because I would be if I cook that [__]
and here we are in a current situation
on her ass and the chef over there wants
to [__] laugh about it
you're standing there [__] Smiled On
Me Off you just showed me over the last
three minutes your attitude stinks and
you can't take criticism if there's ways
and mean to go on about I'm putting
criticism across it's the way you speak
speak arrogantly how would you like to
be spoken to just like a normal person
like anyone would speak to anyone
no let's go the other way shall we
please be so kind to remove the the
apricots from the mashed potato
I don't know how I mean listen we've got
a problem here yeah and there's a
[__] issue with the food now [__]
Mr chipmunk in the [__] corners
pissed off the fact that I'm telling him
something constructive if I can't get
over that hurdle I might as well [__]
off back on the train now do you
understand have a word with a chef
excuse me if you want to talk to me I'm
talking to the owner like I'm a [__]
kid [__] me did you like anything about
the three courses there was one Saving
Grace yeah there was there's sticky
toffee pudding was [__] delicious
well thank you God I just wish I had it
for my [__] starter
[Applause]
that's the nitty-gritty over with anyway
s great potential then trying to [__]
tell the chef some form of constructed
criticism he's got a problem not just
with his food but with his [__] gob
you've got every right to be slightly
[__] off about it because I would be
if I cook that [__] Morgan's Restaurant
is an all-woman-run business trouble is
it's not being run very well and Chef
over there wants to [__] laugh about
it
me off
it's serving mountains of expensive
starch
but there's a much bigger problem the
women can't decide who's in charge a
recipe for disaster
[Music]
it's a struggle sometimes and you know
we kick off and we scream each other and
stuff do you know what's wrong with our
heart just is a nightmare and I've
resigned so many times
Sandy claims to be running Morgans but I
wonder how good a manager she really is
I've decided to look at her accounts and
find out
come on good price how long have you
been here uh about two years nice so
where's the office
so they're here
that's that's the office there yeah God
how'd you manage I don't it's difficult
it needs to be bigger bloody hell it's
hell because I can't lay anything out
well look at it all jammed in there like
oh no I know
Sandy's account books I completely
Haywire where's your target
what have you gone out of it in three
years
money financially yeah
well we haven't
how much we've lost in three years I
don't know
Running a Restaurant is a full-time job
not an occasional Hobby
if Sandy can't even organize the books
it's little wonder she's hired a chef
whose mouth is bigger than his talent
all right Chef good morning morning how
are you not too bad for you yeah yeah
slightly concerned but um a good sleep
yourself no not a good careful damn why
because I lost slate both that was last
night this is today that's a good
attitude today's another day we live and
live how long are you cooking
Phil's got more confidence than ability
he's never had any formal training but
Sandy makes his job tougher because she
won't pay him for Preparation time the
menu right it's just basically been
thrown together I'm not allowed to come
in at night in the morning
well Sandy doesn't want us to come in at
nine o'clock in the morning how'd you
get ready for service
I come in at four o'clock and the
tickets are throwing it together even I
can't get [__] ready from four
o'clock in the afternoon now it's
starting to make sense why are you
[__] so defensive totally understand
it's not entirely your [__] fault
what I want to do is [__] work
together on it no sound I look forward
to it you still want to punch me no I'll
save it tomorrow safe that's all next
week
okay good
two hours before Saturday's service
Morgan's only busy night of the week
[Music]
with no preparation done the kitchen's
in chaos there's not even enough food
labels and just odds and sods thrown in
here
[__] dog [__] so what do you need now
for service
because the place looks fast if there's
30 people come in for dinner
it's freaking me out as well
beans bread prawns and is this normal
this time afternoon for you to go off to
the shops like that yeah so you don't
actually get the stuff back then for at
least another hour sometimes you don't
get until six o'clock
when the customers are walking through
the door
fat man unbelievable the headshot should
order supplies but Sandy's been buying
from a supermarket because she doesn't
want to pay Phil to do it for her
before we get any further what I wanted
to say to both of you is a [__]
Supermarket is not good enough no
questions or any chance of [__]
surviving yeah the cost we've spoken if
we had a dinner party at home we would
be sat here at [__] four o'clock
looking for a [__] list let alone
running a [__] restaurant
beans okay French beans vegetables I
think beans beans beans oh God no no
beans held around the next one
no no the the slice they're pre-packed
[__] you know
sorry [__] him this way do you want
real what's good what did we get
yesterday I think it was raw yeah yeah
you sure how many would you like it oh
okay
a couple of um well a few pounds all of
those and some more if you have
this is ridiculous you know that
[Music]
Sandy's Panic buying fillet steak but
she should have had it delivered from a
cheaper wholesaler
Sandy it's [__] five past five
where's the fillet steak
well it's here somewhere
sirloin
[Music]
there must know where coming no that's
never happened before
rub steak rum steak no
thank you
how much is that please
53.89 if we had to buy this produce on
last night's take-ins we'll be 30 quid
[__] sure I've got a [__] headache
let's go
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
seven o'clock and the restaurant is
filling up
Morgan's is a stunning beautiful [__]
restaurant unfortunately the food is
[__] the chef's way inexperienced he's
self-taught and he's cooking with
[__] expensive ingredients bought
from the local supermarket and Sandy is
just another prime example of an
individual that's open to Russian
without having a clue how to run one
tonight I'm going to be watching Phil
closely
Phil's menu is poorly designed but can
he actually cook
what you're cooking yeah standards now
yeah are you happy with that no no no am
I you're a chef hey not a [__]
Coleman no no
[Music]
I feel just plain careless and I won't
put up with it
[Music]
puzzle
[__] you now
kitchen started to act like [__]
slobs and happy to cook charcoal and
then send it that's not good [__]
ridiculous I'll tell you what he's
[__] sharp memories it's always got
weird ears isn't it
his eyes are [__] everywhere
my customer has sent back a creme brulee
it's like [__] baby vomit do you know
what it goes like that
quick West too fast under the girl [__]
you know don't eat that unless you're
prepared to die Phil's biggest problem
is that he just doesn't concentrate he's
simply out of his depth making silly
mistakes I just feel as if I'm just not
in control at all of your own [__]
kid your own job
Chef Dottie Sandy's supposed to be in
charge of this mess
you're helping out the washer yeah
Sandy's interfering everywhere doing
everyone else's job and achieving
nothing
are you lost
are you wondering what to do I'm good
I'm I'm trying to do a little bit of
evidence do I know that you are what is
your role tonight what what exactly are
you doing well we wait now
waiting on what tables tables okay now
you're doing
have you seen the size of that [__]
he's more capable of washing his own
[__] play I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
do it online welcome to the [__]
lunatic asylum
Sandy's so busy doing the dishes that
she forgot her customer's order for
gravy
you've been waiting 15 minutes and
complains to Helen so the three main
courses from that table and one guy sat
there with his sausage yeah looking for
some [__] sauce why is no one being
straight with you and telling what they
need what do they want excuse me
you've got to stop kidding yourself he's
not quite happy today have cleared their
main courses
it's like a [__] kindergarten here
you know that
no is it [__] catering life nothing like
it no it's a shambolic not catering at
all [__] me I love the gravy film
um at least five minutes at least five
minutes
my [__] ass
I asked for a uh some kind of sauce or a
gravy which came took a while to come uh
to be fair 15 minutes they're
thereabouts and I paid 15 quid
At Last I understand what I'm facing the
chef slip shot concentration is
producing terrible food
but he was hired by Sandy and she's the
real problem and Emma's a restaurateur
messing in the business she knows
nothing about
it's depressing to watch a restaurant
sink this low
that's the saddest main cause I've ever
seen in my entire life
39 years of age and seeing that
[Music]
I want to know if anyone is going to
take responsibility for tonight's
catastrophe
what did you experience out there
tonight in general
um
a lot of people were quite happy out
there to be honest with you you know
I've had no complaints all night what
fascinates me about you
is you're either totally [__]
oblivious to what's going on in your own
establishment or you're [__] living a
nightmare inside your your mind you
cannot see what's going on I can't see
what's going on God I'm not stupid I'm
not a stupid I can't see what's going on
but I can't deal with all these things
on my own I've been trying to keep this
float for three years by doing a little
bit of everything well thank you okay uh
Helen it's diabolical
thank you and you know what you're the
most [__] honest person in here you
know that
and the more honest you're going to be
okay the more chance this place has got
a [__] survival good night good night
thanks good
[Music]
50 of British restaurants close down
within three years often because they're
naive owners know nothing about the
business
Sandy and her daughters can't decide
who's in charge their sibling rivalry
simmering away Helen and Laura are both
desperate to control the restaurant
but from what I've seen only one sister
stands out there's certain issues with
family and my sister wants to do it and
I want to do it and we're at the moment
shown between each other and I think
what we need is a kick up the backside
and we all need to realize that you know
this is it and we need one person to
control it are you capable of running
this place you personally yeah
I am capable of running it I think I'm
the practical
fantastic but
but very similar and
a bit we are in the [__] are we not yeah
definitely that's the reason why I need
to open things up yeah everything come
out
identify the issues and and start
tackling them
to save the restaurant there's got to be
a radical management Shaker so today I'm
going to be cruel to be kind all I saw
last night was just individuals running
around like headless chickens acting
like children hence the reason why we're
in a [__] playground
right
bollocks no chance no chance this is
this is serious now
you sadly whether you like it or not
okay are not capable of becoming a
general manager in that establishment
we've got far too many chiefs yeah I
agree with you insufficient Indians
she can't do it no she goes and washes
up for 15 minutes to make sure the
kitchen Port is there next week and
she's going to delegate job so I agree
with you make sure that what she's doing
it's a restaurant manager's job your job
your house
you're the host
meeting and greeting and sitting people
down yes yeah happy with that
your position is the assistant manager
yeah who's the manager don't get
defensive can I just do one at a time
yes yeah no one's leading unless you've
got the phone sorry to interrupt you
though I was away last night and if I
had been there things maybe would have
been slightly different okay but the
whole shoulders of the restaurant wait
on you know you coming in you wouldn't
have changed anything last night because
it was just dire it was shambolic
sweetheart and it was best with the
interest not to be there last night
excuse me
one thing you've got is balls yeah I
like the way that you [__] blatantly
know what the problems are but you've
got to get it off your chest you know
that and what are you scared about being
a manager confrontation
no it's not so much that it's actually
being given sole responsibility because
at the moment yeah and my sister's just
walked off there because she's obviously
you're going to come in or
yeah
thank you
maybe you can prove yourself you know
it's fine this is not a discussion to
separate YouTube or drive you of course
okay but unfortunately one two three I
do all the same job sorry you've got it
completely wrong let me just finish what
I'm trying to say and once we've all
defined our roles then we can put it
into the pot yeah and clearly you're
upset
clearly upset and that is a stinky
attitude how can you walk away like a
child who's ran the business on my own
when these two were on holiday together
you tell these two to do my role I'm
sorry typical typical we decide typical
works so well good you know so what I'm
trying to do is to sit down I know we
haven't been here are you running away
come over come over
grow up calm down what about the big
sister here you're not even listening
calm down it's back in the morning calm
down yeah yeah Laura it's completely
stupid walking off let him walk off let
her walk off
what's your role
general manager at front of house
bollocks no chance Morgan's Restaurant
was being run like a ladies lunch Club
until I made Helen general manager one
thing you've got is balls you know that
her sister Laura didn't like it one bit
you tell these people do my role
typical well that's tough they either
change or go bankrupt Morgans can only
Survive by attracting local people
before I redesign the menu I'll have to
find out what they really want what'd
you look for when you're at your local
eatery I have something quick
um tasty simple have you heard of
Morgans yes and feedback you're too good
what would you look for in your local
restaurants to be treated stuff and to
be treated as an individual good and how
much do you expect to pay for dinner
what would you be happy with I don't pay
with my friends will pay
[Music]
Morgan's menu belongs in a bad expensive
Gastropub my plan is to modernize it
with fresh ingredients and lower the
prices
stripped It Back to Basics and homed in
on good local honest produce and kept it
very very simple something light vibrant
a salmon for instance potion a really
nice autumnal broth but it doesn't get
any better than that
[Music]
I'm gonna buy one item here something
simple something local
Morgan's middle class neighborhood is
full of Foodies they love fresh tasty
ingredients served up in healthy
attractive dishes incredibly Sandy and
Phil haven't realized this even though
there's a great Organic Market on their
doorstep
nice to meet you it's slightly Dotty
guess what you get some meat from uh
also to the supermarket it is a
supermarket yeah that's right however
that stop now and we're gonna look for
some damn steak something simple
something local and something not too
expensive okay
this is excellent locally produced lamb
gives a little bit of excitement from
The Waitresses to sort of eight this is
local organic lamb V we got it from the
farmer's market this morning in our
street and just starts to make you feel
a little bit more [__] romantic thank
you
we'll be 53 or six we don't do Tesco
Club Points
okay lamb steaks yes yes a little bit
Rosemary a little bit of garlic yeah it
feels a self-taught chef who knows very
little so I'll have to start from
scratch with him what you've got to do
is just remember you're stepping up to
the challenge huh big time this lamb
steak is my first dish designed for
Morgan's traditional menu
get some color on there not quite we'll
serve it for Sunday lunch tomorrow
and then finally yeah gravy lamb sauce
over the top now if anyone complains
paying 12.50 for a lamb steak it's clean
it's local it's fresh that for me oozes
value for money
it's just about going back to basics
really simple dish tasty easy to do
he just wants me to succeedly
[Music]
Sunday isn't a day of rest in the
restaurant business there's lots of
money to be made incredibly Morgan's was
closed on Sundays but to test my new
team and my new menu I've decided to
open for lunch
it's Helen's day off so sensitive
assistant manager Laura is in charge
or supposed to be
[Music]
today was a big chance to impress me
she says she's got a business degree
Laura
so who's running it today no the manager
said none of us all called I'm not sure
whether Laura is in today so who's
leading it today who's running the
[__] restroom today
probably will she be it
what's worse is Laura's responsibility
to sort out the reservations
where's the table plan for today
we're just the chefs
my host Sandy hasn't turned up either
the [__] clock thickens that's
things in the chest last night so this
place needs a person to come in the
morning open up and [__] Inspire
everyone check on the kitchen work with
the kitchen table plan and give some
oomph but it's like a it's like a free
house how do you know that
it's 12 45 and Laura's still not here
oh hi uh Laura and good afternoon it's
Gordon I'm in the restaurants I can't
believe I'm chasing the management to
come into work in their own restaurant
on such a crucial day
[Music]
I've been told Sandy's at home resting
Sunday Sunday
but she won't even answer
[Music]
oh [__] now
Sunday Bloody Sunday
if you're not prepared to face up the
responsibility of running a [__]
business then why open it in the first
place
[Music]
Laura finally turns up but no apology
to cap it all she can't even find her
own table plan has anybody seen the page
out the box no the first customers are
due in 20 minutes two hours ago we were
in the same you know situation as well I
said are we looking for it now she's
just being rude
Laura come here a minute come here a
minute come here is this because things
run quite smoothly last night so it's
like a ploy to sort of mess things up
I'll run the [__] show if you don't
show me some form of [__] business
study that you've been [__] harping
on you've got well stop being so [__]
stupid now you're blaming me for the
[__] reservation book two hours ago
when you're in bed we're in here looking
for the [__] thing it's gone can we
move on and try to get some form of
shape in this restaurant isn't that the
most sensible thing to do but let me
just tell you what I've witnessed in the
last three hours here hello you can
shake your head and run off again this
time I don't give a [__] but don't dare
blame me for this chaotic mess yeah
oh not again not again
not again bollocks
unbelievable
hi Helen
I'm desperate for a real manager I'm
just concerned Helen you know that I'm
just like [__] staff I've gone but
the tour in the kitchen okay thank you
bye-bye
Helen's on her way in but I have to run
it until she gets here
Emma who deserve the starters come
around and jump on the main courses yeah
how are you welcome good to see you
now we're up against it a birthday party
for 12 have turned up unannounced today
please so you've got a nice clean yeah
area to think and [__] work with you
welcome good to see you it's been a bit
of a manic morning for Sunday just face
the music and dance at least someone's
happy about
architect of the universe make us truly
thankful
with filling the kitchen they might well
need the almighty's help I hope to God
he remembers what I've taught him
[Music]
now I'm reduced to waiting on tables
it's how I started out the birthday man
himself thank you you're allowed a
second portion and the third
professional soup
what's wrong talk to me I forgot to put
the sauce on come on come on think
concentrate concentrate come on what I
need in here hey excuse to stay on top
of it you know that yeah yeah before you
start sending that main course in your
mind have a little rehearsal lamb
cabbage potato carrot sauce just run it
through and the more you test your mind
you can't forget
the Cavalry has arrived at last Helen am
I happy to see you what I'm more pissed
with anything it's just the most amazing
[__] potential lunch fully booked
waiting this for lunch and [__] yeah
a golden opportunity going down the
drain yeah however you're here yeah
stabilize the ship thank you for all
your help
[Music]
come on Phil don't forget what's in the
oven and start organizing hangers start
dressing nine main courses with Emma
Emma yes yeah
filled concentration deserts him and
he's making charcoal again
[Music]
at least one Chef here has high
standards
Phil sous chef Emma turns out to be a
dark horse she's quick diligent and
passionate her talents go beyond sticky
toffee pudding Phil can't cope without
her it's like home cooking isn't it it's
like this has really kicked everything
into touch now it's beautiful
means a while to me to sit busy on a
Sunday because it just wasn't and that's
why I'm here now so that things go well
and we take a lot of money and
we'll be all back next Sunday I was
right to put Helen hell in the arch
we've just about got away with it
but with Sandy ignoring me and Laura
straps is not good enough you gotta
understand I'm feeling sick I arrived
here this morning
and it was pandemonium
so whilst I totally respect you weren't
feeling well I could still do all your
support you have my support we're
drawing a line today and we're moving
forward it's not a lifestyle it's a
business and we're going to treat it
like a business
I want you to let your Chef do his job
and if he doesn't do that job get rid of
him really sorry but if you don't
[__] act and cook and run this place
like a head chef and don't expect to be
here
foreign
I've been really struggling with how to
relaunch this shambolic restaurant but
I've had an idea to invite some local
celebrities and create a stir around
here it's listed with Wags actresses and
actors hollyoaks is filmed around the
corner and it's a perfect opportunity to
get some really good publicity for the
restaurant so it's neighborhoods and the
minute anyone spots anyone famous in
there they'll want to descend upon it so
that creates a buzz
it's a Race Against Time for Phil he's
got to master some classic and healthy
recipes to lure those ladies who lunch
taste tell me what that means
it's good Emma's the best thing in the
kitchen with her helping Phil we may
succeed with the relaunch you are the
second chef
there's no reason why not you can't run
this place down the line in his day off
yeah
I really mean that and if you can be
that passionate about a sticky toffee
pudding [__] knows what you're going to
be like when you're let loose on [__]
meat or fish huh
for the relaunch I thought of a new role
for Sandy to stop her meddling
why don't we for the first time ever in
between courses start auctioning off
some of these items oh wow very famous
yeah
selling antiques is what she's good at
and there's plenty around to keep her
occupied just in between courses yeah
the great thing is of all he's actually
defined everyone's Rail and that's it
man we're all going to stick to it and
life should be a lot better
[Music]
fully booked for the relaunch today and
I'm nervous
I've staked my reputation on Morgans
[Music]
into my strategy is Phil's ability to
cook my new menu but I'm still not
convinced about him Fried Chicken in
skin side down first
olive oil Why Not Butter
yeah he has to concentrate on getting
the basics right
you can just slow down for me and
[__] think a little bit harder we're
[__] 90 of the way there you know
that yeah yeah do not get distracted
excellent morning good morning how are
you
come through come through
come through all right
just going through two or three dishes
chicken with the lentils and the poached
salmon in an awesome broth
a nice crispy skin
tasty very tasty
realize the potential here
48 book for tonight normal restaurants
are struggling to get [__] five in
it's time for a pep talk and my ragtag
team needs some help
even from sensitive flowers
Laura has finished Sulkin and has
decided to lend a hand
Laura welcome back thank you concerned
about assistant manager manager or just
concerned about running the place just
concerned that the place is running
smoothly good I've still expected him to
Roar
but for now
I'm quite happy I'm quite stable he
unsettles me
[Laughter]
[Music]
[__] big night tonight yeah it could
be something quite major don't [__] it
and the [__] hits the fan we stay United
we've all got our jobs to do with no
interference
no interference I'm very happy I'm very
happy to take a backseat the celebrities
have taken the bait first in are
hollyoaks stars Sarah Dunn and Jennifer
Biddle
the footballer's wives have come too
including Louise Owen Michael's wife and
next thing is Sherry Murphy where Wags
hang out others will surely follow my
strategy has paid off good to see you
hungry yes it's gonna be dessert as well
yeah one of those skinny minis here
they've got proper proper proper Foodies
okay who doesn't need to be behind the
bar there's no one on the floor there's
five people behind the bar Helen's
cracking the Whip and keeping Sandy and
the waitresses in line
the new menus go down well can I get the
roast chicken recipe it's table seven
but Phil has a problem
you took it on table six and there's no
check in the kitchen and nothing on the
top there an order has gone missing and
the customers are waiting so we've been
waiting 20 minutes and you're going sort
it out please
it was the
um
start us out straight away please then
yeah it's not your fault yeah when I had
it one salmon one chicken one lamb
please Phil yeah try and push that
tablecloth I don't know I might like
tonight Joey thanks for the kitchen
salad that's all I'm saying
oh God
two risottos yes yes good man don't drop
yeah
will Phil keep his concentration and
cook my menu well enough to impress
Walton's glitterati this is two more
[__] nothing it's very hard to keep
[__] compensation
despite the cock-up everyone seems happy
I just hope the customers want to bid
for Sandy's antiques
[Applause]
Sandy may be clueless about running
restaurants but when it comes to selling
antiques she's a natural Mr Robinson
what are we going to start at our house
keep shaking
[Music]
70 over there 80 90. 100 pounds that's
your bid
dirty Chef's a Happy Chef like a pig in
[__]
let's go we have table 10 45 thank you
we're setting up 45 in Paris now
[Music]
cash but what do they think of the food
it's very nice
it's delicious actually because it's a
bit crispy but it's also very tender as
well it's lovely really really nice I'm
really impressed I definitely come back
again it's been somewhere that I've
never actually come along to because
I've heard good and bad things about it
but um yeah definitely come back Phil's
cooked his heart out and not burnt a
thing
a few more in control
as he sees as he just [__] knocked
the salts over [__] up what a SWAT
Emma's played a vital role too I just
think it's gone well today it's been a
pleasure to work today actually
selling at 65 pounds Morgan's is
transformed just a week ago it was in
chaos under Dottie Sandy serving up
tasteless Dodge from a supermarket
140 pounds thank you very much
all right good
how much you've taken [__] selling
the Antiques what do we sell that's five
six hundred pounds five six hundred
fantastic sorry in 15 minutes
yeah it's [__] good news [__] hell
tonight you found your role
don't take that the wrong way but that's
what you're good at doing I agree with
you and you have been the toughest nut
I've ever attempted to crack yeah yeah
okay dining room
I just want you two to combine no one's
in competition with each other you know
you both have an amazing [__] role
yeah
the kitchen solid I cannot tell you the
difference from tonight
in comparison to what went on seven days
ago is extraordinary and the minute
you start changing it and reverting back
to the old ways
you're [__]
[Music]
I'm back in Liverpool it's a month after
I turned failing Bistro Morgans into a
pack Neighborhood Restaurant
in development Helen's told me that
following around she's let someone go
I'm on the search for Phil
um he's left Morgan's and uh you still
have Camp here so uh
done to get hold of him find out what
the [__] going on really
Jesus
what the [__] are you doing here
good to see you feel yourself you're
looking well I feel well what happened
she said about him she had loads of
complaints sold my services man not
required no more there's not a lot I can
do about it now sort of moved on and I
ended up put me in my honey
without me there Phil's concentration
went again but it's actually good news
now as a sous chef he'll train under an
experienced head chef
chance to stay focused to what I'm
supposed to do listen
and concentrate more on your job
just feel less stressed do you want to
take that please it's for the best that
fillers left Morgan's and I'm pleased
for him
I'm off to the restaurant to find out
the owner's side of the story I'm
worried about what's happened to my menu
and just who's cooking it
slightly nervous
because it was a month ago [__] hard
work
and I came across an owner that was
totally clueless when it came to running
a business
ladies
yeah that's fantastic news my biggest
worry about Phil was the level of his
concentration we had to let him go
thought that you know where we want to
be in them or was the next step and
she's been there for us and dedicated
and 100 we've had fun so
hello so Emma
Dark Horse of the kitchen has been
rewarded for all her hard work have you
taken the Reigns
I've tried to um get more confidence I
remember you saying
to me oh Emma's got very authoritative
in the kitchen and please I'm so pleased
that means the whole place is being run
by females by female
is working [__] well I'm dying to eat
I can't believe it the beef looks
fantastic out there with a sluric mash
braised beef yeah and braised with
apricots
head chefs are predominantly male and
they're just good that I'm having to go
and someone's given me the chance to
have a go and stop to me to prove myself
now so last week we took just under 4
000 pounds yeah Helen's computerized the
accounts
a big contrast to Sandy's chaos week
before I came here you barely hit 1500
pounds we wear loose and then we broke
even and now we're in profit and we have
done for three weeks we've been in
profit you seem a lot more confident
than you did from a month ago yeah in
terms of your role yeah defined well
people have sort of had confidence in me
which is the you know the first thing
about you can portray what you want to
do and put your foot down and people
don't listen to you but once you've been
given a defined role and people start
believing in you then yeah it actually
gives you power and wings to want to fly
and do what you do
great to see the restaurant full and
Emma is so tuned into the menu that
she's even added a dish of her own
braised beef thank you
[Music]
look how tender that beef is he's just
falling apart almost like he's melting
on your fork
wow
it's so upsetting you know that I think
about the dinner I had last time I was
here just came
is delicious
food was delicious really good
absolutely spot on I wanted to impress
you yeah you suddenly did that don't
stop
yeah good night good night ladies thank
you not a man in sight
online
the ladies of Morgans are now making
money against all the odds girl power
has saved this restaurant
I'm happy Morgan's is now running as a
neighborhood restaurant Helen's in
control of the business Emma clearly
knows what the [__] she's doing in the
kitchen and she seems so much more
confident happy customers happy staff
and the food was delicious thank God for
that Morgans
this week I'm in Norfolk home of Alan
Partridge
[Music]
he's not the only one hit wonder in town
[__]
step forward Michelin star winner Nick
Anderson as soon as you say oh I'm the
chef owner of Rococo
that oh wow you know it does stand for
something but Nick stuck in the past and
he's about to lose the lot everyone's so
dead stuck in a rut and this place is
gonna [__] close unless you do
something about it now he's got to say
avoir and aha to his former glories it's
it's trophies isn't it right now they're
going in the [__] bin they are
history Bring it on I can't spell it any
clearer we are [__]
[Music]
King's Lynn a traditional Market town on
the Norfolk Coast where the order of the
day is cheap and cheerful local crab
lest that is you're eating It Rococo one
of kingsland's most expensive
restaurants run by former Michelin star
winner Nick Anderson
I'm very proud when people say you know
who are you and what do you do and as
soon as you say oh I'm the chef owner of
Rococo
they're oh wow you know it does stand
for something
or at least it used to
now Rococo is struggling to survive
the debts are mounting and there's no
real clear Way Forward
Nick's losing 2 000 pounds a week and is
facing closure and if that wasn't Tough
Enough he lives above the rest and with
his wife and two kids they'll all be
homeless if Rococo goes under
well first though is for the boys
because what would we do I mean we'd
have no we'd have no money oh just be so
depressing and miserable
we used to be very very busy and I don't
think we're doing anything differently
and
we're just not getting the people it's
like you know you've organized a special
party and everybody's decided they're
not going to bother coming
I'm here in King's Lynn and I've got
just one week to savor Coco from ruin
and put Nick back in the game
well I really really hope you like
Nick's food
the reasonably confident he's not going
to sort of put his Fork down and go
that's disgusting or anything like that
that's a fairly confident that my food
will will stand the test beautiful
Church
how fortunate and irrational being
next to there
Jesus looks like a [__] sofa bed in
the window
how are you
hey good to see you um is Nick here he
is indeed thank you this is uh quaint
cool very small isn't it hello hello hi
how are you nice to meet you likewise
good to see you how are you I'm all
right yeah you look very warm huh very
hot spoiling at me it doesn't seem very
busy out there no it's just it's falling
away all the time you know tonight eight
people yeah on a Saturday night eight
eight customers booked how would you
describe Rococo Rococo is a full a la
carte restaurant yep
um what style of food is it modern
British I mean we're in the height of
Summer now so everything's sort of well
I'm about I'm about I'm about to have a
menu change this is we're just coming at
the end of the spring menu now we're
going into the summer spring we're in
the [__] July spring yeah two months
ago well I'm right right I'll go in the
dining room I'll see you after lunch
okay thank you
right
come down
Tiny Kitchen Jesus it's not going to
visit your Gran I'll read the menu here
thank you
so claustrophobic in here huge Sofas in
the little quaint room
[__]
I may have a glass of orange juice
please
um is it cold
with ice it will be and the Orange is
already chilled yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying is it fridge yeah yeah no I
said thank you
smart ass pan roasted cauliflower puree
white raisin Caper dressing that sounds
very familiar
Nick's got one of my dishes on the menu
he's been cooking for as long as I have
and he's charging Top London prices so I
just hope his food measures up
first test a fish soup excellent and uh
smells
off
well that certainly seen better days I
just hope I won't be saying the same
about Nick by the end of the lunch
[Music]
next mushroom and a duck egg on toast
and it's one of my favorites when it's
done how I like it simply why is it
supposed to be looking like something
out of a [__] Barbie's doll's house
why can't I just look simple plain and
mushrooms on toast it's like using a wet
flannel
soggy horrible bread
mushrooms are dirty
Nick's obviously a Thrills man but if
he's got any sense he'll serve the next
Dish as it was intended because it's one
of mine
and where did this dish originate from
the idea you couldn't no no good asking
for me will you yeah sure thank you
[Music]
thank [__] I don't serve mine like that
they taste Frozen unfortunately milky
and uh yeah rubbery so it tastes like
they were frozen they're a Milky yeah
Frozen
Nick's got to be joking he'd better put
a smile on my face with the next dish
because so far this lunch had been
miserable
it's nearly there just wondering if
there's any point in sending it to be
honest
you Nick I wouldn't keep me waiting
[Music]
thank you
I'm you're like a hemorrhoid in my
[__] you know that can I just sit and
enjoy or try to enjoy rather than trying
to dissect everything I eat otherwise
you might as well [__] sit down here
and take my place would you mind yeah
thank you so much
I'm nervous I say stupid things I don't
need at least you're not having to cook
for it
that sauce is so sweet it's unbelievable
the duck itself actually tastes quite
nice but then it's marred with all that
horrible sauce
it's almost like benellin and baby veg
20 quid as well I mean you know even by
London prices that's you know that's up
there there's someone here that's trying
to clash and he may have got away with
that in the 90s but in 2006
these days are numbered
right Nick you're not gonna lie on what
I'm about to say I expected a nice quick
fast easy lunch and unfortunately
everything was painful you know
mushrooms on toast was supposed to be
mushrooms and toast I got something that
was incredibly soggy full of grits and
just looked horrendous
the duck was [__] delicious and then
everything else around it was so
unnecessary
you were [__] successful 10 years ago
and you had a big following
unfortunately nothing has moved on no
you're in the bubble
and I'm about to burst it
sounds these Laurels clearly cooking
still from the 90s era touch success but
that fizzled very very quickly evenly
Zone customers haven't sort of hung
around long enough to tell him how
[__] long-winded the foods become so
it's yeah it's quite sad in a way and
he's clearly not cooking for King's Lynn
he's cooking for his ego I feel slightly
deflated I didn't think I'd get as much
criticism as I got but hey I'm a big boy
I'm not a 20 year old I'm not going to
cry I'm 40. so yeah
Bring It On
this week I'm in King's Lynn to help
Nick Anderson a chef who once had a
Michelin star
sauce is so sweet it's unbelievable it's
almost like beneley but after eating his
food yesterday I'd say he's Glory days
are long gone
I expected a nice quick fast easy lunch
and unfortunately everything was painful
four years ago Nick was flying high
running a successful restaurant at the
crown hotel in Wales
I had a business turning over a quarter
of a million pounds a year got to six
out of ten in the good food guide two
AAA rosettes and a mission star in 2001
uh 2002 2003 for three years
but in 2004 Nick crashed and burned when
he and his backers parted company he's
never got over it it was a very tough
time leaving Wells and
um obviously very emotionally draining
we just found out Susanna was pregnant
obviously I then had the best part of a
year on the Dole
um bankruptcy and trying obviously to to
find some way of getting back Nick open
Rococo hoping to get back on his feet
but with no one coming in to eat there
he's now hemorrhaging money
this morning I want to know what the
locals have got against Rococo
[Music]
no have you heard about Rococo what's
the reputation in King's Lynn in the
moment it's quite expensive isn't it
when you look at it you think are you
going to get value for money I think
probably too pricey two smaller portions
I don't know it's Kingsland too small
for a restaurant like the Cocos
they've hit the nail on the head except
for one thing it's not King's Ling
that's the problem Rococo's has gone way
past Itself by date
I mean pretentious food stuffy service
and [__] ridiculous prices even for
London ridiculous prices
before I can drag Nick into the real
world I want to find out how he runs his
kitchen so I've arranged to meet him and
his sous chef Tim Sanford before
tonight's service
absolutely no one no one in at all no
[__] me that's extraordinary how'd you
leave the boredom how do you stimulate
yourself in terms of coming up with new
ideas and it sounds absolutely Dreadful
but sometimes I do watch Ready Steady
cook and I pick up little things on that
yeah [__] me yeah I know it's Dreadful
you're the first chef I've ever ever met
uh it's becoming
that's become excited and stimulated on
the back of Ready Steady [__] and just
take me through your fridges like meat
fridge where would that be
so I have my my duck my lamb good
looking sausages they sound nice to lose
are they actually from Toulouse yes they
are amazing this is basically fish
trimming scallop corals for fish soup
rice pudding Madeleine mix fine Nick's
veggies are packed with the best
ingredients but no one's coming to eat
it all is he mad
you have the most extraordinary
ingredients yeah and if you don't sell
it you eat it yeah things like you know
Meat and Fish so really it's a big
advantage of the restaurant being
[__] empty because you live like a
king
amazing no it's not food here Tim must
be [__] extraordinary it is huh yeah
well you look well on it thank you it's
not me
if Nick's in trouble he could be buying
cheaper produce on his doorstep so why
isn't he with things like the shrimps in
the freezer yeah are you on the you're
on an S3 you know 20 miles we struggle
to get them fresh we always used to be
able to get them fresh oh seriously you
mustn't forget I have been doing my
homework yeah I've been here I know how
many boats are still like fish are Fleet
the fish on Saturday I can tell you
what's in the market tomorrow morning
trust me okay oh [__] me
feeding niggs having me on
everything has to look Immaculate with
the best of cheesy and the best of
sausage and the best of rack of lamb
he's in King's Lynn yeah not sat in the
[__] Harbor of Monaco and every
customer hasn't got five grand to blow
on a [__] bottle of wine
before I tackle the business I need to
see what Tim and Nick are capable of and
so I want to watch them in action during
a busy service
but things have sunk solo Rococo the
only way we've been able to fill the
place tonight is by rounding up Nick's
friends and some local business people
and when you opened you know 91 was the
food the same then no the duck egg with
White Marsh I thought that was part of
the history in terms of being on the
menu for a decade it wasn't from the
very beginning but it was just a dish
that sort of came along probably
not yeah not long after 94 something
like that so 12 years not 10 years
Nick's menu belongs in a museum not a
restaurant but I suppose with 12 years
of practice service should be a Doddle
baby veg is such a throwback to the 90s
but Nick's obviously very attached to
them okay
[Music]
is this slow was it me is this normal
pace of service yeah
Nick's so busy primping and preening he
seems to have forgotten the whole point
of being a chef feeding your customers
that's not normal for that to sit there
so long I know I [__] up I forgot the
black pudding and I dropped the pom
puree into the uh
everything just seems so difficult so
long-winded kitchen Solas there's no
atmosphere there's no not only for
someone who's earned these Stripes
Nick's making a hash out of tonight's
service [__]
you're right I just lost some [__]
red wine reduction I'm beginning to
think this is a man who's lost the plot
salads died in the heat
like his [__] creator
so how was that for you absolutely
horrendous is that the normal way to
work yeah
I'm worried because there's so much
[__] around that goes on that is so
unnecessary you're screwing yourselves
painful it's like open heart surgery
without an anesthetic it's [__]
piling crap on top of crap and using
crap on crap everything is [__] so
[__] over tweaked in a way that
you've just gone past any form of
normality with food you think that the
more I add and put in it's just going to
get better it's not
less is more
slagged everything off about my food I'm
disappointed because I think he could
have at least said something along the
lines of I can clearly see you can cook
meat I can clearly see you can cook fish
he could have said something positive to
keep our morale up I do feel
foreign
choked
last night I could see just how much of
a rut Nick has got himself into sticking
with the same old food has stifled he's
cooking and ruined his business
[Music]
I need a way to get him thinking about
the future and not the past
I've spotted a collection of old food
guides he's been holding on to I'd like
him to let them go
who wants to come in and read the good
food guide it's it's trophies isn't it
because you're in there aren't you yeah
that's the kind of stuff you have
upstairs yeah yeah for you know your
your little meditation time you know you
know when you've had a real [__] night
and you're slightly concerned and you
want to sort of you know
increase the size of your [__]
you lay on the bed and cover yourself
and all your good food guides when you
get a write-up in a guide they've judged
you for what
for that year the previous year yes yeah
by then you you'll move down yes so
you're reminiscing right now they're
going in the [__] bin Colin I'll hold
the bag open and you can get them in
yeah
I don't give a [__] how much you paid
for them you know
15 years of History 15 years of
everything else of course it's sad
it's difficult sometimes to accept
changes necessary
um really is
next road to recovery is just starting
he needs to embrace change but after a
decade working with the same dishes I
wonder if you can actually cook anything
new
things have got slightly static
in terms of creativity yes
come here my little [__] Rottweiler
sorry [__] you mentioned to me the other
day about ready steady [__] yeah no no
don't look at me like that come back to
me with some form of inspiration there's
ingredients let's look I've bought some
basic local ingredients and I'm giving
Nick and Tim just 20 minutes to come up
with some dishes that we can make money
on onion leeks potatoes oh look at this
baby here
fresh
beautiful you've both got a bag each
don't copy him and you don't copy him
fine ready yeah how long steady
cook how long you know how long
first time in years Nix faced a
full-size vegetable
aren't you you've seen it on telly you
sat there in front of the [__] sofa
now you're [__] doing it okay Nick
please tell me you're not looking for a
cutter where's my Cutters where's my
Cutters we Nick don't burn your mackerel
don't get Huffy with me
ten seconds to go three two
one so thank you well done to me good
Nick what is it just simply grilled
mackerel a little time some lemon juice
good yeah that's the mackerels on a bed
of saute potatoes with garlic and butter
would you serve that dish in your
restaurant I think so good would you
serve
this dish in this restaurant no I
wouldn't why not
because I think it's crap it needs a lot
of work going through it you think it's
crap yeah and it needs a lot of work
doing to it yeah
yes I did yeah so I could cook it
quicker
you are so paranoid it's unbelievable
presentation is there for 30 seconds
it's the flavor that holds the memory
right Nick good taste
Michael's nice just slightly bitter
inside because the guts are still in
there unfortunately top of the Mackle is
nice I like that Nick's buckled Under
Pressure Tim's held his own but they
both failed the most important test of
all the leaks
and the potato I wanted a soup
as my starter
and then the [__] mackerel of what he
filleted on a [__] warm potato salad
nothing more starter main yeah two pound
38 I've got to make money because I've
got to [__] open my business tomorrow
okay so you don't you both chose to do
one dish the winner is
none of you
lay down
I'm so frustrated because I can't get
anything out of [__] Nick and I gotta
make some big changes in this place
otherwise uh he's [__]
it takes a little while for things to
sink in with me I'm not I'm not uh
really as a rule I'm not an impulsive
person I don't act
you know
um without thinking things through
and I fully suspect that Gordon's going
to get even more frustrated with me as
the week goes on
but I'll probably get more frustrated
with him
[Music]
I'm work out
Coco doesn't have any customers how has
Nick managed to keep the business and
the family afloat for the past 18 months
I'm going to talk to his wife Susanna
we don't go anywhere we don't ever go
out anymore since having children and
there's nowhere to go and we haven't got
any money
um
so I think he needs a sort of real kick
or a boost or a real something to get
him
inspired again and I you know and when
it's not busy and when it's crap like
that he just you know he's miserable
which I suppose you would be anyone
would be yeah [__] yeah how long can you
continue
staying open along these lines not long
the thing that happens is every kind of
six months Nick has a meltdown goes down
for things [__] [__] everything's
what are we gonna do what we're going to
do what we're gonna do we need some
money we need some money if it hadn't
been literally for like a month ago a
couple of friends stroke customers
wanting to invest a little bit of money
into it I can't remember how much it was
now we would it would have gone I think
if I to close the door tonight yeah I
mean [__] bam yeah shut down yeah how
much do I owe tomorrow morning a hundred
100 Grand yeah
it's worse than I thought even though
he's in 100 000 pounds worth of debt
Nick still shelling out on all the
expensive produce he used when he was
doing well
I need to get him to stop
he told me he couldn't buy shrimps on
his doorstep well I don't think he tried
hard enough
one thing I got [__] off last week
with is when you said you can't buy
fresh [__] shrimps these guys go out
every day
hello gentlemen that looks like a good
catch there he told me that he can't get
fresh shrimps
are they fresh from this morning
yeah and is that a normal catch in the
morning
average and you give me [__] because I
get upset because yours are in the
[__] freezer hello yeah no no are we
have a little taste yeah sure yeah or
would you want to stick to your Frozen
ones you [__] ass on that boat let's
go ah unbelievable you'll turn around
and say no let me get let me get my
frozen ones yes who will they are
beautiful
amazing no shrimp is my [__] ass
beautiful see yeah Frozen [__]
shrimps I went to the fishmongers I told
you I went to the fish monkeys another
excuse no more [__] excuses
Nick's excuses won't get him out the
financial [__] and I still don't think
he's faced the fact that his spending
habits have to change and soon
tonight I'm allowing Nick to cook his
menu for the final time I'm going to do
some tough talking to try and Shake him
out of his cocoon sauces like varnish
aren't they why are they so heavy in the
middle of summer
oh [__] now the only way to add the
sauce I wouldn't charge 20 quid for that
in Chelsea
Nicholas
enaki mushrooms they look like [__]
tadpoles on Viagra huh
is it on there because it's Oriental the
word Enoki yes poor bastards are you
ready to stab me yet
oh
what's the idea behind the two sauces
resemblance of the pearl necklace I used
to give on my girlfriend
what a lovely portion of pork
why'd you put the Black Bunny on there
[Music]
there's anything registering in terms of
all that time we're wasting yes farting
and Fanning around I think we can fit 10
more people in and still get it done
within the time frame I feel like
stripping you start bullet naked and
putting a [__] sign on saying
customers come and eat my food
I'm [__] serious
just can't get anything out of him
so hard because he's like in a daze when
I poke him I poke him for a reaction to
wake him up to get him out of that
[__] accomatized attitude and so
every time I want to dig him in the ribs
I want someone to come back to me with
something of a pair of bollocks
it's like he's sort of putting at the
back of his mind it's not really that
important because getting all my
potential ingredients is far more
important than being a hundred grand in
debt I can't
any clearer we are [__]
[Music]
this week I'm in Norfolk to help shake a
chef out of his culinary coma the salt
is like varnish aren't they why are they
so heavy in the middle of summer it's
the only way I know how to swim oh
[__] now last night I tried to get
through to him with some tough love are
you ready to stab me yet no
this morning I'm hoping to start afresh
Nick's in there so why isn't he let me
in
absolutely pathetic
kick me out with the fuzzy the gears
I've taken some [__] in my time but this
is the first time a chef has ever locked
me out of a restaurant
[Music]
I'll sit here and wait till [__]
lunch time I'll go as a pain customer
also
[Music]
what's the matter
Fed Up
can we talk
yeah
I pulled my [__] eyes out last night
where
the same age you've got two kids
upstairs you know depending on this
[__] succeeding you know so you know
yes you're pissed off yeah you hate my
guts but let's just have a go at [__]
working and turning around don't want
you cooking like that because I think
you can do better with half the frails
you can't give up
was there nothing at all about last
night that you saw
as even remotely good if I didn't think
it was possible to turn around I
wouldn't be here
and you wouldn't have asked my [__]
help
unfortunately the reason why you're more
[__] off is the level of sensitivity
I'm glad you feel the way you do because
it shows that you care
well I'm certainly at the bottom that's
for sure
well at least he's talking to me now so
I'm going to strike while the Iron's hot
and hit him with my big idea it's time
to start from scratch
you're gonna have to seriously consider
changing the name I need a unpretentious
a name for people that's like [__] me
get in there Nick any names
not yet must be something in there you
just roll them out to me just shout at
me
for once number eleven no because there
was nothing too formal
the church is called Saint Margaret's I
don't know
maggies
no no it's got nothing to do with you no
no it's a new identity I say maggots you
know in terms of not casualness but just
unpretentious something that everyone
can relate to Nick you're nervous of
maggies I'm not nervous I'm just not
that Keen at all okay I'm just trying to
throw options in the pot
we need a fresh start the name is not
critical
the change is crucial
I don't like the name maggies I think to
me it just says
Maggie's Caravan stop and get a bacon
roll here we go while Nick can still his
own juices over the loss of six letters
of the alphabet but he's not going to
stop me tearing up his menu
anything you're worried about
all that delayed silence [__] me I can
kill you
okay finally a smile I just hope he's
happy with the new food
I've swapped his expensive ingredients
for cheaper local Alternatives so we can
lower the prices and these simple dishes
can be prepared quickly
that is just a nice summery chilled
chunky rustic yeah dispatcher and
there's a duck salad
and fried mackerel on a bed of warm
potatoes one nice fillet
on and a simple cheese souffle
please take a hot oven
220 perfect so you love the name maggies
adore it Chef no I hate it you hate it
why'd you hate it just makes me think of
somewhere that you pick up a bacon
butter at the side of the road ready
yeah what's the alternatives
Nicholas I'm beginning to lose patience
with Nick
time's running out I don't know how long
you think you've got but I can't tell
you any longer here Mr Anderson we're
scared of [__] change no one wants to
change anything because it's safe safe
means we're in the shed no I'm just
trying to inject a bit of energy but
right now like I said no one's no one's
with me on this one no one's clean for
changes no one's Dynamic for changes and
everyone's so dead stuck in a rut and
this place is gonna [__] close unless
you do something about it
what I'm pissed off more than anything I
don't feel anyone [__] pulling on the
rope quite frankly it's not good enough
to sort itself out that's why we're in
the ship so I don't feel that surge of
support that really sort of you know
bang this is all I've got in life it's
not there it's not so if they haven't
got it what [__] chance have I got
I can't work out why Nick won't let go
of the past
I need help from people who know him
best first stop Susanna
I can't work out whether it's just his
pride yep or whether it's you know
saying goodbye to Rococo doing King's
Lynn yeah you're not in Knightsbridge he
thinks Maggie sounds cheap and he
doesn't want his food to be cheap but
we're not turning it into cheap if he's
not happy with that why doesn't he come
back to me with it I don't care if he
calls it Frankie's Maggie's Uncle May's
I don't give a I don't give a toss about
that no
Rococo's myth is feeding his ego nothing
more yeah but I swear to God I look at
that man in the eyes every morning and
there's not 100 Grand of debt in each
[__] eyeball yeah that is wrong yeah
if Nick goes down he's taking everyone
with him wife kids and his staff it's an
amazing place an amazing setting quaint
[__] town hall you know an amazing
square this place should be [__]
rammed people should be queuing up to
stand in a queue to come and eat in here
yeah you've got everything here
I see someone that is hurting yeah for
what reason Glory Days Michelin star
possibly possibly got to be a reason
somewhere I would have said that
four years ago Nick was top of the bill
in Norfolk and his stage was the crown
hotel in Wales
but when he and his back as party
company Nick had to leave the restaurant
I don't think he's ever got over it
this is where it hurts
have you been back in there
um not for a long time no not for a long
time I brought you here to face your
failures
I had a situation once when I had two
Mission stars in a restaurant called
aubergine and I'd work my [__] ass
off for these guys for five years
and because
I didn't want to go down the direction
that they were going down I cut the
[__] cord and I got out of it and
it's been the most important [__] day
of my entire [__] cooking career you
had to turn a new Leaf I've never been
back in that door and I've always wanted
to go in there and just eat
but instead I used to just put it past
yes
and there's like two or three bin bags
outside the front door and you know what
it makes me feel so happy because when I
was there
I used to put out 18 to 20 bin bags and
that told me
they're nowhere near as busy it was it
was that moment when you think the most
important day of my entire life turning
the [__] leaf
and for the short time I've known you I
don't think you've ever turned the leaf
no
that was then yeah this is now
why didn't the [__] penny drop
earlier I don't know stubbornness maybe
I don't know I've been massaging my own
ego with the food
without seeing the fact that why are the
other restaurants busy because they're
not trying to be pretentious you have
got to start afresh [__] move on
it's taking me the best part of a week
but I think Nick may have finally got
the message
[Music]
it's my last day in Norfolk tonight we
relaunched the restaurant and there's
good news
I've made a decision Gordon I'm going to
run with maggies maggots doesn't mean
it's a [__] greasy spoon no in six
months time the name is irrelevant but
it's the news that's where I got it's
just perfectly honest why get all
precious about it skip skip thank you
everyone
[Music]
now I need another miracle we've got to
get the people of Kingsland to give
Nick's new restaurant a go I just hope
they can forgive his sins I just want to
tell you about our new restaurant okay
it's a replacement of Rococo's Saturday
Marketplace yeah well it used to be no
you haven't you liar yeah no you have
anything you've just been called maggots
today you've changed the name we've
changed the interior it's affordable the
food's great now I've got through to
Nick there's no stopping him he's agreed
to dump the intimidating 90s decor and
replace it with a simple and fresh
interior
[Music]
um tomorrow about eight o'clock you've
got a reservation there yeah well done
come on when you get going can't stop
you you know that huh
we've only got a few hours left to clear
out the final traces of Rococo before we
throw open the doors at Maggie's but
something's already made it back in from
the bin
no they're not going back I'm just going
to take them upstairs you're taking them
upstairs
what are you doing with the guides well
it's history isn't it
just when I thought I was [__]
getting somewhere
have you got any paraffin
look at them ever
is your photo in any of them names never
been photos
you don't need them [__] me
now
where else have you sneaked back into
nothing nothing
finally all the old-fashioned remnants
of a Coco have been stripped out and in
its place his mag is relaxed informal
and most important welcoming
created a fixed price menu made up of
modern rustic dishes the big pool for
the locals will be the cost at 21 pounds
it's half the price of Rococo
big night tonight
um 44 booked oh yes 42 44 yeah can we
take any more loans yeah yeah if we can
do them yeah yeah definitely if Maggie's
does 54 covers tonight I'm running
around that square and the cemetery
start bollock baking menu everything at
the menu three starters three main
courses and three desserts yeah
we've gone through all the [__] you
know rollercoaster highly strung highly
emotional upsetting bullying it's all
gone tonight is the night really make it
work good luck thank you all for your
very hard work this week and let's make
Maggie's work
if we get through this one tonight and
he pulls it off you know
I'll be not happy of course I'll be like
happy my worries in the kitchen not with
Tim but with Nick if he gets in the [__]
early on let's hope he's got the
Charisma the personality the drive the
determination to get out of it this is
not just a man starting off afresh this
is a man that is desperately in the ship
up his eyeballs with 100 Grand of debt
and [__] me every plate he cooks he has
to really seriously mean it
[Music]
chicken mackerel lamb
nice absolutely stunning good
two super late they're very hot launched
please be careful yes
excellent starter's gone within seven
minutes fantastic
magazines filling up with the locals
there'll be more people in tonight than
Nick would usually have in all
weekly when you are okay duck down yeah
[Music]
despite the fact that we got rid of
Nick's fancy ingredients he's still
fiddling he can't afford to switch off
tonight well those little burnt bits the
potatoes
come on come on come on come on Nick get
Tim to put the piece around there okay
don't keep on squashing it down tomorrow
calm down slow down guys and work as a
team like you're sort of almost in love
with each other there you go
the new menu is doing the trick the pace
is picked up in the kitchen but it's
getting busy and now Nick has taken his
eye off the orders potato is already
gone thank you what do you mean where's
that ticket please Tim what is going on
thank you that's all I want what is
going on I don't know what's going this
never happens
it's just Nick stop my man yeah we're
doing the same course again twice all
right the next order is a chicken and a
mackerel
chicken take
that one with you
just screwed himself they've just
started to cook one table's order twice
over brilliant it doesn't need to be as
panicky as it is [__] me this is home
cooking big deep breath and just compose
yourself and be comfortable doing three
or four things at the same time and
bring it together the Russian is now at
his busiest so if Nick doesn't take
control now we're in trouble
come on service please have three suit
plays out yep that's tonight doing it
this is like three duck yeah
yes sure
and you've got your sides on the go yes
you've got your side orders on the go
check the saute it's gonna be carrots
gone
finally for the for the first time this
week
how big it takes to Ronnie's restaurant
20 seconds 30 seconds
replacing the chicken Tim are you ready
for that souffle nearly chef
and I think next even enjoyed himself
just uh you know that no just
so Nick's had a good night but are we
back in favor with the locals I think
the prices are right
all right come and have a meal on an a
regular basis rather than at just a
special occasion which it used to be
definitely come again
Nick's got the stamp of approval making
a fresh start has worked so if Nick
wants to bask in the glory again it
better stick to the new regime
how do you feel
good
good seriously yes treats him yeah we've
just taken about two and a half Grand
and we've got for a shaky start can you
do it again tomorrow that's the big
question yes you can yeah good I'm glad
to hear it I can't do any more and it's
over to you now yeah
this is just the beginning and it's
going to go forward and it's going to
evolve and it's going to get better and
better and better
um and it's just that it will never be
it'll never be what it was because
clearly there weren't enough people
coming for what it was so it needs to be
different
and watch this space tonight's service
was a tough one tough but we got there
can they cope on the back of that
performance tonight it's gonna be very
tough for them to cope very very tough
indeed because they're gonna have to
wake up in terms of that's normal I'm
nervous about this one more than any
other restaurant I've ever worked in
because I don't feel that surge of
excitement to get it right
foreign
[Music]
I spent the week trying to convince Nick
Anderson that his glory days were long
gone
argue with me come back to me
by the end of the week we've not just
change the food we've launched a brand
new restaurant maggies
skip skip
seven weeks later I'm back in Kingsland
to make an unexpected visit
nice whole roasted lemon Soul local with
cockle butter
wow the first change is obvious Nick's
got customers nice Buzz very nice purse
good evening good evening how are you
well good to see you yeah good evening
Chef how are you very well thank you
Timmy how are you smashing good man
thank you
hey you have got your [__] together uh
seriously uh turnover
um we're averaging four and a half to
five grand a week two weeks been eight
top week's been out yeah that's great
one big question have you got a spare
table of one anywhere yep for that I'm
not gonna always wear not eating
the first thing that's took me when I
walked in here you know was the bus the
place is full 47 kilos on a Wednesday
night
King's Wings empty yeah this must be the
busiest place within miles
the exciting thing about the menu is
everything's sourced locally which is
nice um if it tastes as good as it reads
then
it's down to him
he can't pop this one I'll go for the um
I'll solve the local salt please with a
cup of butter um and just maybe before I
start can I try uh onion I'm trying to
figure out what the [__] they're doing
here where did that one come from Timmy
I think suggested it Timmy the cat Timmy
the cat so far so good but I'm reserving
judgment until after I've eaten
not the kind of thing you expect to find
on the menu here however it's [__]
delicious so who am I to complain there
is nothing pretentious about what's
being put on the plate here and the
minute the food arrives you don't think
about some pretentious Chef in the
corner trying to massage his ego it's
good honest simple food that's all it
has to be it's not [__] rocket
science
lovely and that's local you only ask me
how my dinner is yet
Jesus fish cocoa butter parsley sauteed
local sets and soda potatoes
rustic simple and so unpretentious is
extraordinary and
miles in front to White experienced the
last time around here
unfortunately
that was nice Nick very nice simple
honest and great flavors for you what's
changed in terms of I've got it I've got
it back in here have you though yeah is
it is it in there yeah this is the first
time I can quite honestly say and I mean
really [__] honestly you're cooking
for your customers not your ego it's
only gonna be a matter of time before
you're financially [__] stable there
already seriously Batman's paid right up
today all the supplies are back within
30 days and the wine supplies paid up up
scratched
I've given you my recipes
you've had a personality transplant
haven't you where'd you get this from a
lot more chefs I like to give it to tell
me where the shop is I'll send the
[__] to it
all jumps apart don't [__] change no
and don't put your [__] ego in front
of yourself tomorrow don't put your
[__] ego in front of your customers
your success is the buzzing that dying I
mean that buzzer's gone it [__] me keep
it there definitely yes yep well done
thank you how do you mean that oh thank
you stubborn [__] but well done
yeah I'm amazed what a [__]
turnaround extraordinary good
honest simple food local produce great
service no bits of [__] with olive
oil and all pretentious crap everywhere
no [__] flea bitten sofas out there
no canape is just a really good evening
nice buzz and I really hope he [__]
makes it he's got a recipe for Success
here and um he'd be stupid to change it
pretty good